we have the graphs of three functions
here and what we know is that one of
them is the function f another is the
first derivative of F and then the third
is the second derivative of F and our
goal is to figure out which function is
which which one is f which is the first
derivative and which is a second like
always pause this video and see if you
can work through it on your own before
we do it together all right now let's do
this together the way I'm going to
tackle it is I'm going to try to sketch
what we can about the derivatives of
each of these graphs or each of the
functions represented by these graphs so
in this first graph here in this orange
color we can see that the slope is quite
positive here but then it becomes less
and less and less positive up until this
point where the slope is going to be 0
and then it becomes more and more and
more and more negative so the derivative
of this curve right over here or the
function represented by this curve it's
gonna start off reasonably positive
right over there at this point the
derivative is gonna cross 0 because our
derivative is 0 they our slope of the
tangent line and then it's going to get
more and more negative or at least over
the interval that we see so it might
look I don't know something like this I
don't know if it's a line or not it
might be some type of a curve but it go
it might go it would definitely have a
trend something like that now we can
immediately tell that this blue graph is
not the derivative of this orange graph
its trend is opposite over that interval
it's going from being negative to
positive as opposed to be going from
positive to negative so we can rule out
the blue graph as being the derivative
of the orange graph but what about this
magenta graph it does have right it does
look like it has the right trend in fact
it intersects the x-axis at the right
place right over there and at least over
this interval it seems it's positive
from here to here so it's positive this
graph is positive when the slope of the
tangent line here is positive and this
graph is negative when the slope of the
tangent line here is negative now one
thing that might be causing some unease
to immediately say that this last graph
is the derivative of the first one is
we're not used to situations where
has more extreme points more minima and
maxima than the original function but in
this case it could just be because we
don't see the entire original function
so for example if this last graph is
indeed the derivative of this first
graph then what we see is our derivative
is our graph our derivative is negative
right over here but then right around
here it starts becoming less negative so
that point corresponds to roughly right
over there
then over here our slope will become
become less and less and less negative
and then at this point our slope would
become zero which would be right around
there so for example our graph might
look something like this we just didn't
see it it fell off of the part of the
graph that we actually showed so I would
actually say that this is a good
candidate for being the third function
is a good candidate for being the
derivative of the first function so
maybe we could say that this is f and
that this is f Prime now let's look at
the second graph what would its
derivative look like so over here our
slope is quite negative and it becomes
less and less and less negative until we
go right over here where our slope is
zero so our derivative would intersect
the x-axis right over there it would
start out negative and it would become
less and less and less negative and at
this point it crosses the x-axis and
then it becomes more and more positive
so we see here our derivative becomes
more and more positive but then right
around here it seems like it's getting
less positive again so it might look
something might look something like this
where over here it's becoming less
positive again less positive less
positive less positive right over here
our derivative would be zero so we our
derivative would intersect the x-axis
there and then it just looks like it is
the slope is getting more and more and
more negative so our dream is going to
get more and more and more negative well
what I very roughly just sketched out
looks an awful lot like the brown graph
right over here so this brown graph does
indeed look like the derivative of this
blue graph so what I would say is that
this is actually f and then this would
be f prime and then if this is f prime
the derivative of that is
to be F prime prime so that looks good I
would actually go with this and if you
wanted just for safe measure you could
try to sketch out what the derivative of
this graph would be and actually let's
just do that so over here the derivative
of this so right now we have a positive
slope of our tangent line is getting
less and less positive it hits zero
right over there so the derivative might
look something like this over that
interval now the slope of the tangent
line is getting more and more and more
and more negative right until about that
point so it's getting more and more and
more negative until about that point and
now it looks like it's getting less and
less and less and less negative all the
way until the derivative goes back to
being zero and then it looks like it's
getting more and more and more and more
positive so the derivative of this
magenta curve looks like an
upward-opening you and we don't see that
over here so we could feel good that
it's derivative actually isn't depicted
so I feel good calling the middle graph
F they're calling the left graph F prime
and calling the right graph the second
derivative